omma has experienced much misery she's
not giving her real name to protect
family back in syria bashar al assad's
massacres forced her to leave via
Lebanon to Cyprus but life here is not
happy so do you think the government do
you think Cyprus as a country wants you
here no it's a racist country the day
after their ship arrived four months ago
Omar's husband was arrested he's not
being prosecuted but police won't say
why they're not releasing him only that
they think he's a security threat we
came from an unjust country we came from
oppression from Bashar al-assad Syria
then we came to this country thinking
there's justice democracy and human
rights things aren't much better for
many other asylum seekers people queue
for menial jobs and meager welfare
coupons through the night to be one of
the lucky few seen by a handful of staff
during office hours asylum applications
can take many years to complete
it's an overwhelmed and confusing system
as more arduous routes into Europe are
restricted the relatively simple journey
from Turkey to the self-declared
Republic of Northern Cyprus then into
the South becomes more travelled 15,000
now have refugee status here upwards of
15,000 more applications are pending now
these aren't huge numbers on the global
scheme of things certainly compared to
the millions of refugees in Turkey but
Cyprus is a tiny country and it now has
the highest number of asylum seekers per
capita of anywhere in the European Union
Cyprus is interior minister says they
need European help because the system is
that breaking point if turkey spoon is
continuously pushing people to across
the green line to Cyprus they are
entering the European territory it's not
a Cyprus problem anymore
in my creation is it's a European
problem but some on the ground see
things differently Dorris Polycarp who
runs Kisa a refugee focused NGO he's
critical of Europe's inaction but he
says Cyprus has created a hostile
environment to make itself a less
attractive destination if you don't do
your job and you are in fear that the
society will blame you for the situation
is very easy to say Europe is
responsible for the north straw in
solidarity instead of saying that we
missed and we didn't do what we should
do
as with all refugee stories where the
government's are unable or unwilling to
cope it's real people who suffer rory
challenge al jazeera Cyprus